pour un amas tous et les dif et où
l'attend aura duré près de dix mois
les deux soeurs originaires du cameroun
devait arriver en alberta en avril 2020
résidence permanente en poche elle avait
quitté leur emploi leur logement à
douala et acheter leurs billets d'avion
nous avions tout préparer comme il faut
on atteindrait de recevoir nos visas
bref tout était parfait arrivé que leur
faible la frontière s'ensuivent
plusieurs mois où les deux soeurs
doivent refaire de nombreuses démarches
administratives et sont obligés de
puiser dans leurs économies
finalement elles ont réussi à quitter le
cameroun il y a quelques semaines comme
un matou et lady fait tous les futurs
résidents permanents francophones qui
choisissent l'alberta peuvent compter
sur l'aide de la cité des rocheuses à
calgary avant la pandémie cet
accompagnement pré départ comme on
l'appelle durait deux ou trois mois
environ aujourd'hui cela fait parfois un
an que les immigrants attendent de
pouvoir partir j'ai beaucoup de clients
qui était vraiment sur le départ donc
qu'il y avait des scolarisés les enfants
à d'autres qui avaient déjà acheté deux
maisons canada certains qui ont leurs
vêtements et leurs meubles qui sont dans
deux conteneurs et qui sont chantées
depuis plusieurs mois pour l'instant
seuls les immigrants qui ont reçu leur
confirmation de résidence permanente
avant le 18 mars 2020 peuvent venir
s'installer au canada
pour les autres il n'y a rien d'autre à
faire que d'attendre c'est le cas
d'aminé qui vit en algérie
immigration canada a terminé l'examen de
son dossier mais depuis il a été mis en
suspens en attendant amine s'est déjà
fait de nombreux contacts en alberta il
a repéré les endroits où ils aimeraient
habiter et malgré le décalage horaire il
a même commencé une formation à
l'université de calgary
il ya des moments de panique de crainte
tellement de choses reposent sur le
projet de migration tellement
d'investissement sfr tous les organismes
qui offrent le service pré départ ce
sont eux aussi adaptés à cette nouvelle
réalité que c'était un aspect qui ne
faisait pas partie a directement de
notre mandat mais âge
la frustration de nos clients parce que
c'est comme ça qu'ils se sentent ok ça
devient ça fait c'est devenue une partie
intégrante de notre service en 2020
l'immigration francophone hors québec a
connu un fort ralentissement presque
partout au canada le nombre de nouveaux
résidents permanents francophone a
baissé de 30 % en moyenne dans les
provinces de l'ouest et de 32 pour cent
à l'échelle du pays
les organismes sont convaincus qu'une
fois les restrictions de voyage lever
les immigrants seront de retour mais la
question encore une fois est de savoir
quand il s'est mis les ja very radio
canada calgary